I give a lot of credit to the
engineering and design team because they
just they're taking it to the next level
so you know I think it's all Camaro it's
it's a true Chevrolet but you know you
look at the performance improvements you
look at the styling I mean it's it's you
know it's more refined but it's still
you know you won't mistake it it's a
Camaro and then the technology in it as
well so just you know every inch of it
has been has been improved what do you
think separates a Camaro lover from a
Corvette lover how do you differentiate
those two markets um you know again I
think it's we go in and what Alan is
team will do is really understand those
customers so I mean like today I mean I
just spent some time talking to
customers and they can tell you every
aspect of the vehicle how it drives the
feel I mean it's kind of that true
muscle car so you know they're there is
a different a different customer I have
to tell you I love both but there is
just a warm spot in my heart for the
Camaro family this has got to be one of
the biggest halo cars though for you how
successful is it to have a product like
that a halo car everybody wants they
come in the showroom and the story goes
that they may leave with a cruise or
Malibu well you know that happened to me
way back when yes I ended up winning
chevette but but no I think it is
important cuz it's a car and I can't
wait to get these on the road because
once you start driving them people I
mean they follow you they you know
probably get a little too close as they
try to look at the vehicle taking
pictures I mean it's a car that
generates that kind of excitement board
had kind of owned the pony car space
throughout this 60s and 70s and 80s and
when you guys came out with this in 2009
you instantly took the crown and held it
until basically now so do you think
you're going to overtake the Mustang
again as they already came out their new
generation well you know we're really
proud of what the previous generation
accomplished of leading and again it was
you know the market telling us bad and I
think when you look at every aspect of
the vehicle I yes I think we will and
that's our goal right that's what we're
in to lead the segment one of the things
i think about is camaro vs mustang is
that a mustang is seen as
be a more palatable car for women and
men the Camaro seems to be very macho
although you prefer it to the Corvette
so what do you think do you can you
market this car better to women yeah I
think there's a lot of women that like
this vehicle I mean I just met five
customers that you know know every inch
of it and know the details just as well
so I I think it attracts a fair number
of both men and women and again it's
those interested in this type of
performance car but I think also when
you look at the refinement that's on
this vehicle I think we'll take it to
the next step and continue to improve in
that space are you going to get your own
Mary I mean I know you're excited about
z28 you're gonna get a new gen-6 oh gosh
um I'm sure at a point you have time do
you have time to focus on cars as much
as you want to but you know what my best
days still are when I'm either at the
design dome walking through the back or
at the milford privy grounds driving
cars and I make sure I get the time to
do because that's our business that's
what we do so you know I I will be
surprised if at some point this doesn't
show up in our garage